Hi Dr Peterson,
thanks for coming.
My question is a little bit off topic
from everything else tonight,
but I really wanted to hear what you had
to say about it.
Um,
I work in residence life here at UBC and
in the community where I am.
We were recently effected by a suicide
of someone who lived in our community
and I was upset about it,
not just because obviously it's a
horrible thing to have happen,
but also because res life in the
university,
like they talk all this talk about like
self care and your mental health is so
important to us.
But then things like this still
happened.
So I wanted to know like if you think
like,
what do you think the university should
be doing to keep stuff like this from
happening in the future?
Well,
it's not self evident that it's the
university's responsibility and the
reason for that.
I'm not saying it isn't.
Okay,
I'm saying it's not self evident that it
is because different institutions can
only do so many things,
you know?
And,
and we were already requiring the
universities to educate and to act as
substitute parents.
Increasingly.
And to take on the role of judge,
jury and executioner as there are more,
what should be criminal cases are being
handled within the university.
Say,
um,
having said that,
you could ask the broader question is,
well,
what do you do to help people be
sufficiently in love with life so that
they don't wish to end it now?
And I've tried to puzzle through that
for a long time and that's partly why
I've written the things that I've
written.
It's partly why I've produced the online
programs that I've produced.
No one.
So we know that if you do,
if you have students do the future
authoring program,
for example,
they're much less likely to drop out of
university about 30 percent less likely
and their grades go up.
And that's especially true if they're
male and marginalized.
It has a bigger impact on those
communities.
And so,
you know,
I've tried to get universities interests
now the data's there,
but they're not.
And it's very difficult to get a big
bureaucracy to move.
A big,
big is immobile.
So I'm not sure there's anything they
can really do about it.
It's certainly possible that the things
that they're trying to do about it or
making it worse.
Yeah.
That's another thing that you learn if
you're a good social scientists,
just like there was evidence,
and I don't know if this is still the
case,
but,
but there was good evidence.
I looked into this about 15 years ago.
Say you want to prevent suicides or
suicide hotline in your town and you
advertise it.
What happens?
Suicide rate goes up because you're
advertising suicide,
right?
And lots of lots of interventions are
like that.
It's really,
really hard to make things better and
it's really,
really easy to make them worse.
And so that's another problem.
You get these big bureaucracies,
let's say,
and there hypothetically motivated by
positive intentions and I would say
hypothetically,
again,
because it takes an awful lot of work to
help someone straightened out.
It's no joke,
especially if they're in real trouble
and they put in place these
structures that are designed to help but
they don't ever evaluate them and they
could easily be making it worse.
So.
So I don't have a straightforward answer
to that question.
Um,
I think that.
Well,
that's,
that's the only answer I have.
Yeah.